What's your name?
-Sachini.
-Where you from?
Austin.
Austin, okay, but where
are you really from?
Just outside of Austin.
Give it up for Chardonnay, everybody.
All right? She's fun.
♪ Almost heaven, West Virginia ♪
♪ Blue Ridge Mountains ♪
It's not a gamble
if I know it's gonna work.
Sometimes you think too much
like an American dreamer.
♪ Country roads, take me home ♪
♪ To the place I belong ♪
Your being a success
is everything to me.
Oh jeez, Sach, what's wrong with you?
My parents are here, and they think
I'm at college in Houston.
They don't know you dropped out?
In this country,
everything has strings.
Don't forget that.
You never know where you're gonna end up.
Only you know what you want.
-What do you have that thing set to?
-80 miles per hour.
-Maybe we should set it to like 40 or--
-Don't touch it!
I thought baseball players drank beer
and ate sunflower seeds.
When does it get fun?
♪ Drivin' down the road, I get a feelin' ♪
♪ That I should've been home yesterday ♪
Shame does you no good.
You deserve to feel amazing.
♪ To the place I belong ♪
You don't want the arm?
You could never be who you were
supposed to be back home.
That is why you have been delivered here.
So do what you came to do.
♪ Take me home, country roads ♪
This is our life now.
And I promise you, it's going to be good.
♪ Take me home, country roads ♪